you may have heard about this last week  Tom Cruise I love Tom Cruise great actor  last week Tom Cruise hurt his ankle  while doing a stunt on the set of  Mission Impossible six was in all the  papers now rest assured he's gonna make  a full recovery  that guy's in great shape yeah so they  say he's gonna fully recover but you  know I looked into it this is nothing  new for Tom Cruise he's always done his  own stunts despite the risk of injury in  fact he's been doing his own stunts as  far back as the early 80s with his  breakout role in risky business I didn't  realize really yeah I was thinking about  it there are a lot of stunts in there  well take a look at some of the outtakes  from one of that film's most iconic  scenes he really goes for it take a look  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  that makes I forgot that movie took  place in the cliffs of Ireland yeah  you